meagan Merkel's taking over NYC the
seven-month pregnant Megan caused a
frenzy while leaving the mark hotel
today in New York the trouser clad
Duchess was of course caressing her baby
bump
her first stop was to the Met Breuer an
art museum overhauled Omega she also had
lunch at the posh Surrey Hotel with her
friend Abigail Spencer earlier in the
day abigail was seen entering the Marc
hotel while holding a gift
Megan's gal pals gathered in New York
reportedly for a baby shower organised
by the Duchess close friend Jessica
Mulroney
it's believed Megan arrived on Friday in
these exclusive photos from the Daily
Mail calm Monday night the Duchess tried
to look incognito in a long navy coat by
Victoria Beckham and a tweed cap atop
her flowing locks not there her mother
Doria Raglan instead of being in New
York today she was spotted in Los
Angeles walking a dog a royal source
tells ET Megan's clandestine New York
trip has been filled with relaxation and
buying baby clothes the getaway was a
way to see her stateside girlfriends
before the royal birth Megan is believed
to be flying back to the UK midweek and
then jetting off to Morocco with Harry
for an official visit after that a
second baby shower in London is expected
most people thought being pretty heavily
pregnant now the Duchess probably
wouldn't be going overseas Megan has
felt very fit and very well throughout
her pregnancy
unlike the Duchess of Cambridge she
hasn't suffered any morning sickness
[Music]